-You know
our first guest tonight
from HBO's hit series "Girls"
and the critically acclaimed
film "Get Out."
She stars in and executive
produced "M3GAN,"
which is in theaters now.
Let's take a look.
-Being a parent was never
in the cards for you.
You're a beautiful, creative,
strong, ambitious young woman.
Your first love is always
gonna be your career,
and you shouldn't have to
feel guilty about that.
Let me focus on Cady
so that you can focus on
the things that matter most
to you.
-M3GAN, do you see this pen?
-You know something, Gemma?
You're exhausting.
Now, I can either do this
with you or without you,
but I'm not gonna waste any more
time discussing it.
-Gemma?
-[ In Gemma's voice ]
Katie, don't come in here.
-Please welcome back to
the show,
our friend,
Allison Williams, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Allison,
I'm so happy to see you!
-I'm so happy to see you!
-It's been -- obviously, a lot
has happened in the world,
but it's been a long time
since you've been here,
and a lot has happened
for you as well.
I want to talk about the movie,
but you had a baby.
-What?
-Yes, you did!
-I did.
-A real one,
not some creepy M3GAN,
a real, actual human baby.
-I had a real, human baby, yeah.
-And engaged as well.
Congratulations on everything.
-Thank you so much. Thank you.
-So I've been lucky
over the years
to get to know your parents
pretty well,
and I know they took
being a parent very seriously.
They were incredibly loving
and supportive.
-When he says that, by the way,
what he means is that
every time he saw my dad
in the buildings --
my dad used to work for NBC --
my dad would say,
"You know my daughter
wants to be an actress."
And you were like,
"It's not up to me."
-Yeah, there's only --
And in fact,
I'm gonna say this now,
because it makes what
you've accomplished
even more impressive --
I did everything to stop it.
[ Laughter ]
-You did?
-Thwarted. Thwarted again!
-And I couldn't manage it.
-You couldn't stop it.
It was inevitable.
-My question was gonna be,
how are they doing
as grandparents?
-Oh, they're obsessed with it.
I guess it's like a drug,
grandparent-ism?
Grandparent-hood?
-Yeah.
-It's like,
intoxicating in this way,
because it's all the love
and none of the responsibility.
And so they just --
they're so into it.
They're so engaged. They're
super helpful. It's the best.
They're funny.
They know all the songs still.
They know "Head, Shoulders,
Knees and Toes" like it was
yesterday.
-Well, there's a lot of clues
within the song
as to where ---
-That's true.
-It's one of the easier
choreographies to remember.
-But the bridge has, you know,
eyes and ears and nose.
-Oh, yeah.
I never get to the bridge.
-Oh, you don't? You skip.
You're just a verse guy.
-I'm just like, "We're just
gonna do the main parts.
Chorus is for high school."
-You're probably like a
one-animal "Old MacDonald."
-Oh, absolutely.
-Oh, gosh.
We do the whole -- anyway.
They're very, very engaged
and amazing.
I'm really lucky.
-You had,
your family came to you,
to the premiere of "M3GAN."
-Yes, that's true.
-This is a lovely photo
of everybody.
-Yes.
-And I want to show
a second photo as well,
'cause here you are.
This is a great
red carpet photo
with a bunch of M3GANs.
Also your dad,
and I should note,
this is the producer of the
film,
Jason Blum.
-That's my boss.
-Yeah.
So you have sort of four
M3GAN look-a-likes
and then a look-not-alike.
[ Laughing ]
But the part I just noticed is
that here's --
look how happy your dad is,
here he is,
to be with his family.
-Yeah.
-And then here's how happy he is
to be with the M3GANs.
[ Laughter ]
So this movie had
a fantastic first weekend,
which is so exciting,
because I think, you know,
anybody who loves movie,
it's really exciting when
people want to go back out to
the theater to see them,
and obviously, you have
the Avatars of the world,
which are sort of
a different thing,
but this is a movie people were
so excited to go to.
It was PG-13, so like,
just people --
I think this was a movie that
people loved the idea of
seeing it in a theater.
What was it like being
at the premiere with
a packed house?
-So fun.
Well, of course I've spent
months watching cuts of it,
just like, on an iPad,
which is, it was great.
I was excited about it,
but seeing it in a full theater
tells you a lot about
humans and human nature,
because about halfway through
our movie,
something truly
messed up happens,
and people were cheering.
And it wasn't
an isolated incident.
It happened again.
I went to another screening
in New York,
full audience, people cheer,
and then there's, like,
a self-loathing laughter
that happens afterwards
where you're like,
"I can't believe
every part of my being,
all cells of my organism
were rooting for
this thing to happen."
And people are like, ugh. Ew!
They, like,
want to shower afterward.
But that's what's so fun
about this movie.
It's fun.
People come out of it and say,
"I had a blast,"
which sounds weird,
'cause you're also
scared the whole time.
But it's funny and it's like --
it's self-aware in a weird way.
But yeah, of course,
we were thrilled
that audiences were having
so much fun with it.
-I think that at this point,
if people are gonna
make that leap
to actually go out of the house
and to see it.
-If you're gonna leave
and pay the $1,000 per ticket...
and do the whole thing,
masks or no masks
or whatever you want to do,
it's a big ask.
-Yeah.
-So I better mean it
when I say you're gonna
have fun, and I do.
I mean it.
You're gonna enjoy it.
-The film was made by people
who understand
that people are gonna
see it together.
I think that self-awareness
means that, like,
look, we know exactly
who this is for,
and that's why I think when
people laugh and people scream
at the same time, part of it
is in appreciation of,
"Oh, the people who made this
movie took care of us."
-Yeah, we made it for you.
-Yeah.
-Like, we built in time for you
to have the responses
that we hoped you
were gonna have.
We had to add time.
At one point --
M3GAN likes to sing and dance
sort of spontaneously,
and one of the moments where
she breaks into song,
we had to add time, because
the laughter in test screenings
took too long,
so that's the kind of thing.
We're making it for you guys.
We're not just making it
for ourselves.
I mean, we're all vain,
obviously.
But it's not that vain.
-It helps a great deal.
-Exactly, exactly.
-We make it for ourselves,
but then we realized --
-Other people are gonna see it.
-Yeah, because we like to
make it for ourselves,
but then we also like to
make money.
-Exactly, and there's
our whole industry.
-We just described showbiz.
-That's showbiz.
-I have so many more questions
for Allison.
We'll be right back with more
after this.